Lexy and Brent Rivera thanks so much for
hanging out with us via zoom today how
are you guys house quarantine life
treatin ya we're pretty good we're we're
hanging in there yeah yeah I keep him
keeping busy you know trying to go for
walks and stuff like that but yeah it's
good so far
lots of family time uh yeah a little too
much time oh but it's always good you
know they hang out with family and yeah
some stuff that you know we didn't have
time to do how would you say this time
together for you two as siblings has
kind of strengthen your bond
um I mean yeah we just have like a lot
of time to kind of just you know make
videos together I think I kind of showed
you know how much we do rely on each
other to like yeah being each other's
content and like um you know it's always
it's always fun when when making videos
with Lexi except like I can't imagine
being it like without like without its
sibling and during this whole thing like
I need someone to like talk to it yeah I
make videos yeah exactly so no one's
getting on each other's nerves at all ya
know there's obviously you know some
tension sometimes but you know we we try
and we try and working out you guys have
been you know creating content for your
fans on social media but not only that
you have this awesomeness TV YouTube
channel series versus and you have a
couple new episodes coming up which was
all done remotely right yes yeah we all
we filmed it all in my living room right
here and we can't just yeah we filmed it
we had like the producers on the other
end and they kinda just like told us you
know seems to do and and and stuff like
that vote it was it was pretty but yeah
and everything went pretty smoothly like
surprisingly everything was there's a
lot of fun I think obviously it's always
fun to goin like the studio and set up
in helmet but you know being home being
in the comfort of your own own home was
yeah it's nice because I could just like
walk to the fridge if I was hungry or
something she's like you know laying my
bed if I was tired so
lunch break takes a whole new meaning
when you're laughing from home I mean
did you guys ever think that you would
be literally creating content shooting a
show from the comfort of your own home
definitely not I think I think you
always think of that stuff yeah I kind
of just like going to other places and
doing it but when you're doing it inside
your home it's like it's definitely
interesting for sure what was it
challenging at all of being you know
having to do everything without any
professional help from producers or
directors like hands-on I mean obviously
you have their direction be a zoom or
you know telephone whatever it is but
you know you got to setup the chords you
got to set up the lights the cameras I
mean was that challenge to get all her I
mean you guys are used to it yeah I mean
I think were kind of used to it just you
know because of YouTube and we're always
someone stuff anyways yeah but there are
a couple different like extra steps you
know extra things you like do that we
wouldn't usually do for like our YouTube
videos or whatever so yeah hey its new
skills that you can you know add to your
resume is what I like to say yeah yeah
so we've got two new episodes coming up
one at the end of this month and one
next month what can you tease for the
fans well there's a lot of I mean oh
yeah I'm some bickering you know like
always but also I think I win it
I don't know don't I'm always now let's
just say like I come out on top a lot so
you know well you guys have to watch it
that's sibling rivalry I love it oh yeah
well Brent the episode that's airing
later this month you dive into what you
really think of the word influencer
which I feel like is such an interesting
topic can you kind of give us a brief
synopsis of kind of your thoughts on
that and what you really think yeah so I
mean basically the word influencer it's
so you know broad it's like you know
obviously someone that like influences
and you know so I think I mean I
personally think that everyone
technically is an influencer because
they do when someone just some point
yeah but I
I do like to refer to like people that
do create a lot of content as like
creators I think it's more the word is
just a little more I don't know like I'd
like the word influencers I know what
you mean yeah it's just I don't know I
would rather be like referred to as like
a creator but right I mean it's not like
a bad like influencer isn't like noise
right yeah but there's a difference
you'd say then from someone who just
influences to people who create content
I mean there's a huge there's a huge
difference right there yeah and as like
a content creator you still are an
influencer technically right could you
influence people with yeah with your
content right yeah that's only one part
of the of creating content is
influencing others right but there's a
lot of other parts so it's almost like
you're just saying you're an influencer
but it's like whoa there's other things
to it I guess right from what you guys
have observed you know seeing your peers
and and whatnot on the platforms during
this pandemic how would you say
influencing has kind of changed because
of coronavirus if it has and maybe
what's next for influencing once this is
all over I think coronavirus really
really brought it kind of like you know
there was a timeline of like you know
how like the the mainstream media and
the you know the social media was like
coming together and it was a little
longer but I think coronavirus kind of
expected expedited that a little bit
because all these you know all these
mainstream media people wanted to get on
social media to kind of like really
engage with their fans during this time
and so like that really like mesh the
two together and I think that there has
been no other time where there's so many
you know behind yeah yeah you know more
videos in they usually do
time but I also noticed like more of a
like brand I've been doing this like
forever like the sibling sort of mom
I've if you will but I feel like now
everyone's doing a family dynamic
because there's there's no one else so I
definitely noticed more of like family
time videos which is cool it's yeah yeah
in such a time in our in our country and
even globally where it's you know you
have people who are divided but then
also strengthened by this one common
thing which is a pandemic kind of
affecting everybody it's been
interesting to see how people are using
their platform to help others are you
proud of the community yeah I think so I
think you know in times like these we do
need people to step up and really you
know make a change and and help people
out and so you know I always try and
look for those people that you know
deserve deserve just recognition in my
videos and stuff and I'll try and give
that to them but um especially like
nowadays ya know in times of need like
no I mean even just you to creating your
videos and choosing this time to still
keep up with that instead of like taking
a break I feel like is so instrumental
and helpful in its own right because you
are giving your fans something to look
forward to in days where there's really
not much to look forward to I mean for
you guys how emotional has that been for
you throughout this knowing that your
videos your content is almost even more
impactful now than ever before
yeah I think I think when this all
started you know obviously it came
across my mind like okay well should I
do you know take a little bit of a break
you know but I knew like I had that in
mind I had like you know I need a you
know these people are reaching out to me
and asking me you know to keep going and
and I'd like to make that content for
them and every every time I post a video
especially on YouTube like I always see
comments saying like this you know I'm
so glad you here entertaining me through
all this and like it's just really it's
really nice to hear so that I kind of
like take it as a challenge like to
still make content during this time and
and I do it for you know
everyone that like kind of looks up to
me yeah Lexi what about you
well I know that we post on nudes I
don't think we've either of us have ever
skipped a week posting on YouTube so it
would definitely be like difficult
almost to take a break like I don't know
I feel like people are so used to like
every Saturday like clicking on our
videos and watching them I don't know it
would just be hard like tonight I would
yeah if I was following someone you know
it and if something was happening you
know and and they didn't pose like I
would understand but I would also be
like a little sad I'm like oh like I was
looking forward to that this weekend you
know when it's not lights camera action
what is it like in your household when
it's just the family chilling out during
quarantine how are you guys passing the
time um we're getting a lot of Sun here
at the house so I you know we're tanning
a lot we're just kind of hanging out
nothing too crazy so we have like movie
sometimes movie nights just like watch
like different movies yeah was it been
for like dating especially during
quarantines I know everything is like
virtual relationships almost I know yeah
she's been spending time a lot with
would been yeah I see the videos for me
you know you know obviously me and Ava
are just like friends and stuff so she's
you know we're not seeing each other too
often she did uh you know we I did see
her a few times because I missed her dog
and her know but um but yeah I mean we
train yeah see them yeah I feel like
everything right now has been like
facetimes and it's it's like a whole
different ballgame I mean what advice
would you have for people who you know
are either in a relationship or trying
to date during quarantine it's such a
crazy thing I would say maybe just like
if you're not dating someone right now
like chill for a sec okay I want to like
try and like like this is like kind of a
weird time to start like
yeah but then again you have all this
time on your hands so maybe people are
like Oh mines what red is but you can
only go so far with like texting and
like yeah based on you really can't you
know you meet up with someone and then
meet them
IRL in real life I think you only go so
far so yeah maybe just wait if you're in
a relationship you know good luck I can
really test people's health it's whether
it's like your significant other or even
just siblings too it's you know it's a
high but it's so good to see you guys
doing well and we're so happy for you
congratulations on the awesomeness TV
YouTube channel series and everything
guys are doing it was so great to catch
up with you and thank you so much for
taking the time out of your day we
appreciate that thank you so much thank
you as we're talking with you
[Music]